welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker on this
episode I talk with Robin Hansen Robin
is an economist at George Mason
University but even though Robin is an
economist by tidal he's published in a
wide number of fields ranging from
psychology to astrophysics
on this episode we talk about Robin's
theory of grabby aliens
this is a new model that attempts to
explain whether there are aliens in the
universe and where they might be
we discussed how the model works and
what it might tell us about the future
of humanity here is Robin Hansen Robin
thanks for being with us
nice to see you again fantastic all
right let's talk a bit about aliens and
I think the first question we should
cover here is why why do you care about
aliens why have you published paper on
on papers on Aliens
um
isn't this simply too far out to to try
to research
my general intellectual strategy has
been look for important neglected
questions where I can find some original
angle where I could do something new
other people hadn't done
so the topic of aliens just seems
obviously important
uh and when I first started reading
about it I had no particular expectation
that I could have any original
contribution because of course it was of
such interest to so many people how
could I but
um what I've you know learned is that in
fact Academia clumps quite badly and it
just neglects a lot of big important
things
and so I've often had substantial
success just finding a thing that seems
obviously big and important that
academics tend to shy away from
and just diving in
maybe those topics that seem obviously
important to you do not seem obviously
important to other academics maybe
that's the most straightforward
explanation there
I don't think so that is I think if you
just ask Ordinary People what topics are
important there is an awful lot of
agreement and I tend to agree with sort
of you know ordinary people's rough
assessment of things and certainly here
we're just talking about the largest
history across space and time we're just
talking about like the overall cosmology
basically so clearly a lot of people
think cosmology is important
where did the universe come from where
is it going and this is just a big thing
that matters for cosmology if the
universe will fill up with Advanced
aliens then the universe from then on
will be determined by them not by you
know dead matter star Evolution
processes
yeah so we often imagine that we can
look into the very far future of the
universe and predict how galaxies will
move and predict how Stars will spread
apart and so on but maybe this ignores
the possibility of aliens doing
engineering on enormous scale and moving
uh stuff around in the universe that
actually changes things on an on such a
big uh kind of scale level
I think a lot of people just heard I
have a mental block about our future in
terms of its big technological potential
that is it just scares them or it seems
just like just too much or not like not
something they should do in fact many
people sort of invoke a simple
methodological principle of it's
impossible to predict the future yep and
then they they just declare that the
future is off limits because it's
impossible to say anything about and
then they go on with imagining nothing
will happen in the future because uh
that's the simplest thing they think so
just assume the future is like the past
and make and take into account nothing
you know about what's happening lately
and how we're changing things
could this be kind of a heuristic that
people have developed because it's just
so damn hard to
predict what's happening what will
happen in the future and so it's it's
better in some cases not to try and and
maybe that translate into in translates
into a thought that we can't predict the
future at all
I don't buy that so much man I do think
that in fact there's often a planning
you know fallacy or that people often
over plan
and instead of planning they should just
prepare to adapt
and that's in fact a reasonable attitude
toward many kinds of over planning in
our world so for example if you look at
like billion dollar projects in the
world they just tend to go very badly
most billion dollar projects are just
done way over budget way over time don't
work that well and apparently people
just delude themselves into thinking
they are able to do billion dollar
projects
and often it's you know some sort of
political or organizational pride thing
where they're going to make a name for
themselves and be the toast of the world
because they do this big Grant project
and it's just hard to do long projects
so I certainly think there's a
reasonable place for caution there but I
don't think that means you should go all
the way toward we have have no idea what
might happen in the future
yeah and aliens really thinking about
aliens is really one of the biggest
things we could think about maybe a
highly Advanced AI is up there but I
can't really think of of anything other
in that category like if aliens could
really really if they exist affect our
future and the future of the universe so
it's a massive topic to think about
it's not just the future it's also the
past that is just look out into all of
space-time one of the biggest things
that might make a difference out there
in space-time is Advanced aliens I mean
you know they can just make they can
just change a lot so it's just if you're
interested at all on large scales of
space-time it's just an obvious question
that has to occur to you all right let's
get into the the meat of your theory
here uh you have two types of alien
civilizations loud uh civilizations and
quiet civilizations what's the
difference there
well the difference is we ought to be
able to see the loud ones and hear them
so we look out in the universe and we
don't see very much and that doesn't say
much about the choir ones that is the
quiet ones that it'd be small and quiet
and not last very long and not do very
much
are but you know we have a limited
ability to see in here so our limited
ability to see in here is really quite
consistent with a wide range of quiet
aliens
but big loud aliens that we might be
able to see
so it makes sense to at least take our
basic data that we have right now of
what we can see and what we can't see
and confront that with the theory of
loud aliens that is we should be able to
take a space of possible theories about
it and eliminate some of the theories
from consideration
by comparing what we see with what those
theories would predict
so a quiet civilization would be a
civilization like humanity is now so
it's not that that we aren't doing
anything but we're not changing our
solar system or our galaxy in a way
that's visible from very very far away
right I mean the motive is that we do
think it's plausible that in our future
we might become very loud
that is not only might we say change the
sun in terms of its color spectrum a
little bit we might take apart the sun
we might go to the nearest thousand suns
and take them all apart we might go to
the entire galaxy and take it apart and
rearrange it and not just change the
color spectrum a tiny bit but change
where the light comes from or whether
it's light or where all the mass sits
and what it's doing we have some pretty
ambitious plans for the future now they
don't happen immediately that is it
might take 10 million years to achieve
these Visions but 10 million years is a
tiny time on the cosmological scales it
makes almost no difference so if you ask
what might be doing 10 million years
we think there's at least a small chance
we could do some really big things and
then we can focus attention on Aliens
who might be doing those really big
things
why would some alien civilizations be
quiet
well we are quiet now
and so they might not make the
transition to loud
um obviously one way they might just die
or they might freeze themselves into
some limited form that can't grow or
refuses to grow
um or they might choose not to expand so
I actually think uh that'll be the
biggest Choice our descendants will
probably make is to decide whether or
not to allow themselves to expand out
into the universe because once you think
about it there's a lot of downsides to
that
such as
well in the last century or so we have
been becoming together as a world
community in many ways
an amazed that we weren't for the
previous ten thousand years
that was fourteen thousand years ago we
most lived in small forager groups of
maybe 30 people and in those small
groups we didn't actually fight that
much we didn't do Wars we had some maybe
sexual jealousy violence but uh mostly
we decided things together we sat around
the campfire and made key decisions
about who to punish for water when to
move to another place
we're mostly on friendly terms with our
natives
and in the last 10 000 years we lost
that we moved into a world where we have
wars with each other and we're competing
and fighting across the globe but in the
last century we've been slowly drifting
back more toward a world Community where
World Elites at least talk around the
world and when a big thing like covet
happens they all talk together about
what to do and they agree then what to
do and then they all do it pretty much
so Humanity has been moving closer
together and and so your your worry here
would be that if we spread into the
universe we would once again move
further apart and become less able to
communicate we're enjoying the fact that
instead of competing the a war and
fierce business competition we have
agreed at a global level how to limit
War we've agreed on how to regulate many
kinds of business and other activities
and we like this world where we all
decide together on major things and
we're slowly over the next centuries
even have more World governance
where we impose rules more on everyone
to follow the rules and one of the
things that we like about this is that
we will prevent out of control evolution
of our descendants
that is whenever people have talked
about genetic engineering or other signs
of AI even engineering many people don't
like these images they are scared of
them and they think they're dangerous
and they want to have some sort of
collective control over these things to
to limit and manage how our descendants
might become different from us
and that's all possible within a solar
system say that uh is you know
Advanced and uh full of technology and
people but even a solar system is close
enough together that if one part of it
wants to violate the rules other parts
of it can smash them and make them
follow the rules but once we allow any
descendants to leave the solar system
and start creating colonies on other
stars and many thousands of stars
at that point it's no longer possible to
have a civilization-wide governance
civilization-wide conversation where we
agree together on what to do and then
make us all do it and it's not possible
then to prevent
our descendants evolving to become
strange things not only strange things
that violate our Norms but that come
back here to contest for control with us
over this place that's a consequence of
allowing
Interstellar colonization
so this this would push us to stay quiet
as a civilization and it may have pushed
alien civilizations to stay quiet I'm
thinking that when we've when scientists
have speculated about the existence of
aliens traditionally
maybe they've assumed that aliens are
quiet where they've assumed that well we
have no evidence we we are we we can't
see any any aliens so we have to go back
to uh reasoning from from first
principles say and they've been using uh
what's called the Drake equation uh to
do this which is taking
about uh basically proportions of
planets that could be habitable and then
getting smaller and smaller percentages
uh of planets that could that could
house aliens and then thinking thinking
in in terms of this equation about how
many aliens there would be do you think
we've traditionally assumed that aliens
would be quiet
I think that's been a dominant
assumption in the world now a long time
ago some people in this space in
astrophysics reasoning about agents did
consider the possibility that aliens
would
expand enormously and have an enormous
impact on the universe and
I think a lot of people just were
repelled by that vision
and it sort of conflicted with their
politics even
and a lot of people have sort of
expressed the Axiom that advanced aliens
would have to be peaceful and and not
aggressive because otherwise they would
have destroyed themselves and so the
vision that they had for our future is
the vision that they insisted would be
the only feasible vision for aliens and
that would be a way that they could tell
other people today that we should follow
their Vision because otherwise we will
not
and so they had a political lesson about
that they were saying look the only way
to be a long lasting you know successful
alien civilization is to become peaceful
and non-aggressive and environment
ecologically aware et cetera and they
wanted that message
to go out to the world here today that
that's what we should become and that
message would be affirmed by their claim
that no aliens ever do otherwise because
if they do otherwise they die so
thinking about loud aliens expansive
alien civil alien civilizations that
expand and so on was maybe this line of
thinking was rejected on irrational
grounds well political grounds political
grounds okay but maybe the distinction
there is isn't always perfectly clear
they had an agenda a story they wanted
to tell yeah but you can see how that
could animate our descendants to choose
not to allow expansion
yeah all right but
what you've been theorizing about is
basically loud aliens so
um let's dig into the moving parts of of
your model here you have a you call it
grabby aliens and this is just to say
that grabby aliens expand into the
universe and they grab more and more uh
more bigger and bigger regions of the
universe so
one one thing you you claim is that loud
aliens they will make changes
planet-sized changes to to their regions
and they will expand fast
so
why would we expect alien civilizations
to expect to expand fast well our model
has three parameters so it's not a very
complicated model uh there's two
parameters of when they appear in space
and time so we assume they appear at
random places on the on the grand scale
of things
and that they appear in time according
to a power law which has a constant and
a power in it the constant you know just
says an overall rate and the power is in
terms of a set of hard steps that have
to be achieved in order to reach an
advanced level like ours and then they
expand at some speed so the key
assumption is just they they all expand
at roughly the same speed
presumably some roughly maximum feasible
but we don't actually assume it's a fast
speed we we conclude it's a fast speed
from our data so the space of models
says it could be a slow speed and then
our data says no it can't be a slow
speed it must be a fast speed maybe you
could explain why it must be a fast
speed based on the data
so again we have these three parameters
and the key idea is that each of the
three parameters is going to be fit to
data
so our current date we're going to
assume is a random sample from the dates
at which Advanced aliens appear because
we may not become loud but if we do
it'll be in the next 10 million years so
that means at our current data 14
billion years since the big band this is
a random sample from the date at which
such alien species appear that's our
first datum is our current date
our second datum is the history of life
on Earth which gives us a clue to how
many hard steps happened in the history
of life on Earth roughly six
and therefore the time appearance
function has a power of six
things appear more and more rapidly as
the sixth power of time
what what are these hard steps what is
an example of a hard steps is it the
evolution of life on Earth or
multicellular organisms something like
this so the idea is that life has to go
through a sequence of stages where in
each stage it's searching for the next
stage there's a vast space of
possibilities at searching and defining
the key Arrangement that will allow the
next stage
and that we don't really know what these
stages are we have a number of
candidates for them say photosynthesis
multicellularity eukaryotes sexual
selection
Etc but what we
do see is that life appeared on Earth at
a certain date
and we can then consider the very first
step as the has happening before that
date
and then we know that we've appeared at
a certain date right now before life on
Earth will no longer be possible and the
simple theory of Statistics says that
these two durations are samples from the
same distribution of duration of Step
sizes so the first one took roughly 400
million years and now we have roughly a
billion years remaining
and those two numbers are samples from
the typical step duration size and
that's what lets us say there's probably
roughly six steps you know three to nine
or something like that steps that happen
during the history of Earth so far and
so we don't need to know which steps
they were
what we mainly need to know is how many
of them there are and we can get that
from that first duration and this last
duration and then then we think that
then we think that alien civilizations
will have to go through the same number
of steps in order to reach a level in
which they can expand into the universe
right because if there were different
Paths of evolution that had different
numbers of steps
the one with the smallest number of
steps would be the overwhelmingly more
likely thing to happen so the universe
would mainly be filled of things that
use the smallest number of feasible
steps so that's why we would assume that
our number of steps is the smallest
feasible
okay and then let's try to get back to
this question of why alien civilizations
would expand fast
right so the third parameter is the
speed of expansion so now we can take
the other two parameters and we can do
stochastic simulations of this model
where we model the universe assuming the
number of steps we have and the you know
constant we have from our date
and then we can model different speeds
of expansion and see what they would
imply about
the universe
so if we assume that we are a random
sample from the origin of an advanced
civilization date
we can ask at a random time when an
advanced civilization appears in these
models how many other civilizations can
it see
we can just use the model and simulate
it and calculate that and what we find
is that when they expand slowly
that they ran at An Origin time of when
a typical civilization appears it can
see many other alien civilizations in
the sky and what these are is enormous
spheres in the sky but much larger than
the full moon
where within that sphere everything is
substantially changed but as you're
looking at a sphere of alien
colonization maybe billions of light
years across
in which for billions of years they have
been changing the stuff and our key
prediction is they would have made it
look different somehow exactly how we
don't know but it seems pretty likely
that it would look different just like
on Earth today when there's a forest or
uh Savannah it looks different than
empty Rock
but we in a city looks different than an
empty Savannah that is
you know life and civilization changes
things
but so so the reasoning is that if
civilizations alien civilizations
expanded slowly then we would see them
right therefore they can't be expanding
slowly and we can calculate how fast
they would need to be expanding such
that you know we most likely wouldn't
see them in the sky and that's maybe
roughly half the speed of light so if
they're expanding half the speed of
light then we don't expect to see them
in the sky
and is there some kind of uh anthropic
reasoning involved here when we're when
we're thinking about ourselves as
observers so we're thinking about we we
couldn't exist in a universe in which
alien civilizations had spread out and
basically expanded to fill all regions
and so
yeah could you could you explain whether
there are some anthropic reasoning
involved here
so I mean if you could give a link in
this podcast to our grabby aliens
website where we have a simulation that
you can watch of how gravity alien
civilization scenario plays out yeah
I've watched that it's it's incredibly
interesting uh to see the key
observation is that at a random time
when one civilization is arriving
basically a lot of the rest of the
universe is already full of alien
civilizations
and so at you know at the typical
average time then basically half of the
universe is full of aliens that is half
of the volume of the universe at that
moment is you know occupied by old and
advanced alien civilizations
and so that prediction seems to be at
odds with our looking out in the
universe and seeing nothing nothing at
all zero empty but there's a selection
effect
that is
if there were an alien civilization in
our view
it would be here now instead of us
and then it would have precluded us from
being here at least in a situation where
we would see an empty universe so I mean
the simplest assumption is alien
civilizations just prevent the evolution
of other intelligences within the
Spheres of their control they might
allow some previous existing evolving
planet to stay isolated perhaps but then
it would be within a sphere of
control of
other you know of an advanced
civilization nearby and that's not what
we see so we can definitely conclude we
are not in the middle of a sphere
of an advanced civilization
and therefore
um they would be here now instead of us
if
we could see them
and so that's the main reason we don't
see them the universe we see is empty
because we are arriving right now and
the only way we could be arriving right
now is if our planet and solar system
and near space were just left empty
not being changed by an advanced
civilization but waiting for some
Advanced civilization to appear
one of the conclusions you arrive at is
that Humanity has arrived very early in
the history of the universe maybe you
could give us some some dates here
because it's what is it uh 13.7 year a
billion years since the big big bang and
how how long do we expect the universe
to exist for
so um one Theory you might say is no no
no there are no other aliens in the
universe we are the only ones and it's
all completely empty and that's the
simple explanation for why we don't see
anyone
and
we say no that's not quite right
if you were if the universe were
completely empty and would just wait for
us to appear
as long as it took
then we should expect to appear much
later than we did
so the peak of star formation was about
4 billion years after the beginning of
the universe and then you know the peak
of habitable star formation was perhaps
three times later or something because
at the very beginning the universe there
were all these young stars exploding and
that was pretty harsh for a nearby life
uh but over time the rate at which these
explosions happened was declining and so
um you know there are all there are
these all these planets that formed
about 4 billion years after the universe
started and then they have an enormous
distribution of lifetimes
and the average
star and therefore the average planet
around it will last for 5 trillion years
and some of them will last for hundreds
of trillions of years
the average will last for 5 trillion we
are on an unusually short-lived
star with a shortly of Planet therefore
which so far has only lasted five
billion years and only has another 1
billion years left of habitability on
our planet
so we are very early
in this history of the universe now you
might say well that's because only stars
like us can support life and that just
doesn't seem right to us that is seems
that there must be just a wide range of
different paths by which life could
appear and in particular that ocean
worlds worlds full of water are a
reasonable candidate for places where
life could appear
and that even though small stars have
some problems in terms of say title
locking and flares those really aren't
problems for ocean worlds
and therefore there are many stars with
many planets who could in fact evolve
life
sometime in the next
100 trillion years
so this hard step model I talked about
predicts that if life has to go through
a bunch of hard steps that are all
difficult to finally get to our level
the time at which that will happen will
the prediction is the the probability of
that happening goes is the as time to
the power of the number of hard steps
say six
and therefore if you have a star that
lasts a thousand times longer than our
star say 5 trillion versus 5 billion
then not only is there a thousand times
as much time for life to appear on that
longer live star the chance of it
appearing will be toward the end raised
to the power of 6A which means a
thousand raised to the power of six I.E
10 to the 18th that is
there's a 10 to the 18 larger chance
that advanced Leica like us would appear
late on a much longer this star than it
having appeared on our planet which is
such a short-lived planet in such a
short time
can we can we say anything about the
probability of us having arrived this
early in the universe by chance well the
story here is that we made an assumption
in this model that we were just
analyzing we were assuming the universe
would sit and wait empty until we
appeared
and that's the Assumption we suggest is
wrong
that is at the moment the universe is
filling up with Advanced aliens and in a
few billion years it'll be awful
at which point it'll be too late to show
up so there was a deadline and the
universe would not wait until 5 trillion
years for advanced life to appear and
that's why we couldn't appear
on a longer Loop star and plant it five
trillion years in the future we had to
appear now before the deadline
and that's why the reason you should
believe there are aliens out there is
the day on the clock
that is that's the evidence
you are really early and the plausible
reason you are really early is that
there was a deadline and so that's why
there you know they're out there they're
out there right now filling up the
universe you can't see them but you know
they're there because of the day on the
clock
I'm not
totally sure I'm following this so you
in in the grabby aliens model that
you've developed uh it must be
compatible with us being alone in the
universe like there must be some uh
probability within that model that we
are the only civilization but if I
understand it correctly it's just very
low
um but maybe you could you could go over
again why it is that
we couldn't just be alone and this is
the most straightforward explanation for
um
for us not having discovered any any
alien civilizations so this
relative chance of our appearing Now
versus late depends on two parameters
that we show a graph of in our main
paper
one of the parameters is the number of
hard steps
and the other parameter is how long
lives a star can host life
so if we assume that even the longest
live Stars the planets around them can
host life and then life could wait to
appear then that parameter as it is at
its maximum
and that the other parameter is how many
hard steps I said the history of life on
Earth suggests roughly six
uh and if again if it's you know a
factor of
you know a thousand times longer and six
steps then that's a factor of 10 to the
18. so we are 10 to the 18 early I.E
only one in 10 to the 18 civilizations
would appear earlier than us
under those parameters so
the way to explain
our earliness without invoking our model
of the universe is filling up with
aliens would be to push those two
parameters as far as they could go
toward the you know low end of the
spectrum that is you could say no Long
Live Stars just can't host life it's
just not possible only short-lived stars
like ours can host life that's just it
and then you could also say and there
really weren't very many hard steps it
looks like they were but that was just a
statistical fluke turned out there was
only two steps for one step
and if you could if you're willing to
make those assumptions then you could
say and there then were not terribly
early relative to expectations
if you make those assumptions
and then the universe is empty we're the
only ones when you're thinking about
when we have appeared in the universe
what so are you just taking the the
current time from the from the Big Bang
or because you could also you know it's
it's not entirely obvious
how we date ourselves uh here is it
could we could we date ourselves from
the first emergence of life then we are
three and a half uh billion years
earlier
um or how how do you think about uh how
to date Humanity as a rival well what
we're doing is we're making a simple
statistical model that predicts when
Advanced life would appear so the model
has a planet first has to appear a star
has to have a planet so you have to have
the kind of stars that would have
planets and maybe not the first
generation of stars don't uh but you
know you have a first generation of
stars who creates heavy elements then
the next generation of stars will have
planets
and those that next generation of stars
will have too many explosions going off
nearby because they've got all these
very short-lived stars that are lasting
a short time and exploding but those go
away because they explode
and then a little later we've got a lot
of stars around
with not too many explosions and planets
that can have life and now we have the
weight to win how long it takes for
advanced life to appear so we can
calculate this distribution of which
planets could host life
when they appeared and how long they
last and then we can say for each planet
how long does it take
for advanced life to appear I.E what's
the chances of function of time on that
planet and we're just taking some
integrals here and combining them
and that's what's giving us this
distribution over time of when Advanced
life would appear if the universe would
wait empty for it
and we have a we know we have SIMPLE
models of when stars appear and when the
habitable stars appear and the
distribution of how long they last
and we can just fold that into a simple
mathematical model of when Advanced life
should appear in the history of the
universe and that's the thing we are
using to compare to say that we're early
relative to a model of when we should
expect to appear
you mentioned earlier that if Humanity
expands into the universe we will do so
during the next 10 10 million years why
do you say that
well our Evolution has been enormously
rapid
[Applause]
uh in the last million years really and
perhaps accelerating so yeah and not
just perhaps yeah definitely
accelerating
so so you know there's the history of
life on Earth can be summarized in terms
of eras of increasingly accelerating
growth you know there was the rise of
say animal brains from say half a
million year half a billion years ago
and animal brains were say ruffling
doubling roughly every 30 million years
and then humans arrived with their
especially large Brain which could
support culture and then we started
doubling roughly every quarter million
years
a factor of 120 faster and then
humans switched into a farming mode
which allowed the number of humans to
double roughly every Thousand Years a
factor of 250 times faster
and then a few hundred years ago the
Industrial Revolution appear which has
allowed the economy to double every 15
years which is a factor of 60 faster
and so you know at the rate we've been
growing lately we would easily fill the
entire observable universe in a few
thousand years and we know that's not
going to happen so clearly growth has to
slow down
but still we are capable of very fast
growth at the moment so
it's just really hard to imagine we our
growth would slow down so much that we
couldn't achieve say space flight within
10 million years
do you worry that these modes of
existence for life are arbitrary do you
think that if you take if you took ten
thousand different alien scientists and
ask them to categorize modes of life on
Earth would they come up with the same
modes that you just mentioned for me
here well the key phenomena is going to
be that if you have different parts of
the Earth
that are in different sorts of modes
whichever part is in the mode that grows
fastest will just come to dominate the
rest so there's a selection effect for
finding the fastest growth modes
possible
so on different planets and different
civilizations they may just have
different kinds of modes but they will
all have that same selection effect
they will all start out growing slow and
then different parts of them will bounce
around trying out different new modes
and if they ever find a new mode that
just can grow much faster that new mode
will quickly take over and displace all
the rest
and that's what we've seen so far
that is humans could grow faster than an
animals or displacing the other animals
and then farming could grow faster than
foraging and farming displaced foraging
and Industry could grow faster than
farming and Industry is displaced
farming and then another mode may appear
my book the age of M is on one possible
Theory brain emulations but the key
ideas whatever new mode appears that
could grow much faster than the existing
mode it will just quickly displace the
existing mode and when we're talking
about growth rates now we're talking
about something objective and it is no
longer it's simply a subjective
categorization of modes of life on earth
right that it's about the rate at which
it's
physical power can grow it's direct
physical impact of energy it can command
they matter it can command the things it
can do these things are just growing
at these growth rates
Robin if Humanity manages not to destroy
itself and if we expand into the
universe when will we meet Aliens
so as I said we have a three parameter
model we can fit each of the parameters
to the data the fit is rough but you
know we can get each parameter say
within a factor of four maybe even a
factor of two
and that allows us to estimate a
distribution over these models and we
can ask within each model when do we
meet Aliens and so there's a
distribution here but roughly a billion
years
is when we would
meet Aliens only of course conditional
on our heading out to meet them if we
wait here to meet them then it would
take twice as long because of course
you know we can cut down the speed if
we're traveling and they're traveling at
the same time
but of course we have to last that long
so we would have to become either loud
or very long lasting quiet civilization
in order to meet the aliens what do you
think is most likely that we in what
mode are we most likely to survive by
being quiet and long lasting or by
expanding output
unfortunately I'd say the most likely
scenario is we don't survive
that is most likely we'll be quiet and
most likely we won't survive as quiet
and that would be the most likely
outcome for our civilization it's not
the outcome I'd prefer but it has to be
the one I'd guess
uh so this model I've been talking about
tells us the distribution of loud aliens
in in space it says for example they
appear roughly once per million galaxies
and we meet them in a billion years but
this is only the distribution of the
loud ones now there's a ratio say
between quiet and loud and that ratio is
important for two things one is how
close is the nearest quiet
if there are a million quiet per loud
and they appear once per million
galaxies why then there might be one
quiet per Galaxy and then that suggests
the nearest quiet might be pretty close
but the other thing this ratio
tells us is our chance of becoming loud
we're now quiet and if only one in a
million becomes loud then we only have a
one in a million chance to become that
which is not very good chance so
you know I could believe optimistically
maybe this ratio goes down to one in ten
and then there's only 10 quiet for loud
but that still only gives us a 10 chance
and what determines this ratio
well it's all the different Paths of
civilization could take and what paths
it does take and which of those paths
result in anyone leaving it so the
remarkable fact about Interstellar
colonization is that it only takes one
Colony ship
leaving the solar system that
successfully heads out and lands
somewhere and starts another colony to
end the isolation
and the quietness of our civilization
one Colony ship could make all the
difference
and so to prevent our becoming loud
requires that our descendants basically
prevent that one Colony ship from ever
happening for as long as our
civilization lasts so if our
civilization lasts for a billion years
then every year for the next billion
years they have to prevent any Colony
ships from leaving
that seems like a very difficult task so
so why given that you just said that why
do you believe that Humanity will will
stay quiet will we succeed in preventing
anyone from venturing into the universe
so as I said over the last century or so
we've been slowly accumulating a
stronger World community and lagging
behind that but coming along will be a
stronger World governance we like that
human humans like this world Community
it takes us back to our forager era of
making decisions together and not
allowing rampant
competition to determine what happens we
will get slowly better at
enforcing the wishes of this world
community and World Government
surveillance will get stronger detection
will get stronger
um you know social Conformity pressures
will get stronger
we will just get better at managing this
strong world government and the Strong
World community and I fear and expect
that it will rot
so
systems today that like large software
systems even relatively small ones all
consistently wrought and pretty much all
organisms consistently rot what do you
mean by rot here so in software the the
sign of Rod is that as you change the
software system to make it uh adapt to
changing conditions adding features
changing to Hardware changing customer
desires as you change software systems
the changes you make tend to create more
interdependencies they tend to make the
system less modular
by making it less modular they make it
harder to usefully change so over time
it becomes more fragile more
interdependent and harder to change and
in fact pretty much all large software
systems are thrown away and replaced
wholesale from scratch periodically
that's just our world of software and
most people don't know that about
software
but it's parallel to say biology which
you know produces long-term Evolution
and progress by having many organisms
created that rot over time and then die
and then be replaced by new organisms a
a future human world government would
also rot in a in a way and when you say
that the analogy here is supposed to
to be that it becomes less effective uh
and and even today in say the United
States
we've had one of the longest lived
governments on the earth and therefore
our government systems are one of the
longest live systems on Earth and so if
you look at the slow accumulation of
government agencies and laws and rules I
think we already see rot
we already see that these rules are
getting longer and more interdependent
than allowing less change
uh and that's just the sort of thing you
should expect to see over these long
time scales and other nations haven't
suffered as much because their systems
are newer
do you think that's such a integrated
future for the world would prevent
anyone from leaving and thereby would
would keep us as a quiet civilization
well there's two parts to the story one
is that they would want to prevent
people from leaving
and the other is that they would slowly
accumulate more complexity in the
systems which would include more
regulation and more obstacles and you
know tentacles sort of controlling
Innovation and change such that they
would be better able to prevent The
Finnish dollar colonization that is an
Interstellar Colony will have to build a
big ship somewhere
Philip you know create a launcher of
some sort to support it and it's not
small
and it would be noticeable and it would
require technology supporting
Technologies to be developed
and so that would give the rest of the
civilization plenty of warning to decide
if they approved
if we imagine that we could become more
and more technologically advanced
wouldn't it become easier and easier to
build a spaceship and Venture into the
universe and so you would if it's if
spaceship technology is democratized in
a sense wouldn't there be some group
somewhere who managed to venture into
the universe
yes if you imagine like holding
surveillance and control constant while
you increase local abilities and lower
the local cost of doing something and
raise the total size of the economy then
yes you have to expect an increasing
chance of any one deviation
uh allowing such a thing but I expect
that as technology improves we'll also
be improving centralized control and con
and surveillance and Conformity
pressures
and that we will slow down our ability
to innovate through the rot that such a
centralized system would induce so
there's a race here you see
between our technology improving and
innovating and the slowly accumulating
rot of a world community and government
that will
prevent change so already we are seeing
in the last you know half century many
areas of Technology where innovation has
been slowed greatly or even stopped
because the world Community doesn't like
it say nuclear power
nuclear power at an old physical level
has enormous potential and you know in
before nuclear power started and many
science fiction people imagine quite
reasonably with that when we had it we
would use it and they could calculate
how much we would get out of using it
the visions of a you know vast
technological Advanced future that
people were imagining in say 1930 that
wasn't crazy imagination that was
reasonable given the assumption that
when we had nuclear power we would use
it we have chosen not to use nuclear
power by basically heavily regulating it
and preventing anyone from using it
and we are going to do that with more
and more kinds of Technology
this is your most likely scenario for
the future
but what if we actually managed to
spread into the universe if we meet
another alien civilization in a billion
years as we mentioned before can we say
anything about which civilization
whether Humanity will be most advanced
more advanced or whether the alien
civilization we meet will be more
advanced so I think it's pretty certain
that within say a billion years
we and they will have just asymptoted
with technology we will all just know
all of the technology at least all the
simple physical technology we will
neither side would have a technological
Edge
but they may well be organized
differently and maybe they're a
different form of organization would
make it difficult for us to understand
them and maybe even to strategize
in the light of them and so I think
they'll be very interested to learn
about each other in order to see how
they're organized
and what sort of Social and
organizational Technologies they've
adopted and how far they've gotten with
them
so I think the first thing that will
happen of course is that we would start
to expand right
and then once we started to expand we
would lose that internal coherence we
would lose the central control and then
we would have a lot of competition and
selection there would be Wars there
would be fierce competition that you
know would have destructive side effects
and our descendants would then evolve to
become different and so the first era
here after the era of global
coordination and Global Harmony and all
singing humaya saying standing on the
mountain is that we
spread out and compete and change and
that would be somewhat wrenching and it
could happen very rapidly and then once
we had that we would then continue to
improve our technology but now in a
world of competition and selection
and then we would ask some tote with
technology perhaps within say a million
years or 10 million years and then we
would keep expanding within whatever
degree of coordination we could manage
to achieve at a local level given this
larger scale competition
but then another important thing would
happen before we met other loud aliens
is that we would meet
quiet aliens or their ruins
and that would be the main data that we
would have about the loud ones
we would know about our history
and we would wonder about the history of
the loud aliens we might meet and the
main data we would get is the other
quiet alien civilizations that we might
come across and say get signals from a
distance about when they're still active
or the ruins of them when we finally
physically came across where they had
been
and we'd be extremely interested
in whatever information we could glean
out of The Quiet Ones and for example if
the ratio is a thousand to one then we
expect to see a thousand of them before
we get to the nearest loud one and maybe
we could learn something about how they
never expanded maybe how they came to
destroy themselves and we could learn
something that that we could avoid doing
there and then what for each one we'd
say well if this one had become grabby
had it become loud how would that have
happened and what would they have become
like perhaps we'd be trying to guess for
each one of them what a grabby version
of them would look like
and that would be our best guess about
the actual gravity ones that we'd meet
what if we looked up uh into the sky
tomorrow and discovered
what looks to us to be a grabby alien
civilization what would this mean
well that would mean that there was some
signature of them that was subtler than
I'm expecting
that is when they change their volumes
it's less of a change than I was
expecting but it's still perhaps a
noticeable one so we figure out so the
right frequency and the right sort of
structures to be looking for and we go
aha look at that sphere it's very
different from the stuff around it right
so we'd have identified a Grammy alien
civilization and we could then
immediately estimate how long till they
get here
we could look at the speed at which
they're expanding and see how far away
they are and we know our deadline when
we get here and then when we would meet
them if we headed out to meet them
and
uh you know most likely then this would
mean they were expanding slower than I
had thought when I assumed that we there
are no ones none in the sky and of
course we see one we'll probably see
more if we look in other directions
and we would now estimate the say the
most rapid expansion speed might be a
tenth of the speed of light or even a
20th right we would we would know that
number
and we would then know when we would
meet them
and we would of course you know have our
whole future perception of our our
future changed right
we would know either we choose to stay
quiet and wait till they get here at
which we point we will be at their Mercy
or we will choose to become grabby and
go out and meet them halfway
and we will know that that can only be
done in a certain speed there's it's
just not possible to go faster than
whatever speed we're seeing because
that's probably the fast that's possible
and we would of course want to look at
them and get some sense of what they're
like internally because that's
predicting our future that is whatever
they seem to be like inside is what
we're going to become like and so it's
like looking in a time machine
we would be looking at our future by
looking at their structures and their
patterns but on your model this would be
very unlikely we would we would if we
saw some civilization we would see it
long in advance and we we would see it
by now it wouldn't we wouldn't simply
tomorrow buy some uh better technology
see something that that we hadn't seen
before it's not so much on our model
it's on my judgment that
most likely whatever changes they would
make would be pretty visible now I could
just be wrong about that but that's not
so much from the model as just from this
judgment that
most likely a civilization that has say
been in some space for 100 million years
you know changing things to its Hearts
to content those changes would be pretty
noticeable that's what I've been
presuming but I could just be wrong
about that yeah so your adjustment here
is that
what's the alternative scenario it is
that that an alien civilization would
control a region of space but not do
anything that's visible to us so maybe
maybe what they're doing is is on a very
small scale or is on some some physical
feat there's some physical feature that
we don't understand that they're
changing it would be on a scale of like
many galaxies like there'd be a sphere
that covered you know a thousand or a
million galaxies out there so they would
have moved across a large scale but
somehow they wouldn't be changing these
galaxies very much
somehow they'd be leaving the Stars
alone saying hey so maybe the idea
there's look there's something between
the Stars that's much more useful than
the stars and once you've confined those
things who cares about stars you'll just
ignore the stars because you've got all
this other great stuff to work with you
know and there'd be all this other stuff
we don't even know about so once we saw
that we say hey that other stuff might
be around here too we should go find
that stuff around here with all this
great stuff they could use that isn't
stars because they're apparently doing
stuff and they don't even care about the
stuff maybe it's a civilization that
actually acts like what you described uh
early in this interview a kind of
preserving the ecosystems of different
planets they find in a very coordinated
way but I I just find I just find that's
that's yeah
it's implausible that all of them would
look that way so you could look at one
of them and so we might look at
different ones and say how similar are
they so the more different they are the
more scope there is for each one's
history and system of governance to have
affected what they do okay we we've been
talking about aliens and where they are
and so on is this can we change our
actions in any way if we begin believing
in the grabby aliens model should we do
anything differently based on on this
Theory well most people through history
have thought that cosmology mattered
in the sense that
what you think about where you are in
all the space-time affects how you think
about yourself
it's your place in the universe
so if this is true we have to change our
perception of our place in the universe
us you know ancients when they had a
cosmology it was usually full of active
interesting agents
who
who had agendas and conflicts and their
stories of their cosmologies included
these
powerful agents and their agendas and
their conflicts
lately when we
scientifically Advanced humans have told
the story of our cosmology it's kind of
boring in the sense that it's all dead
there's just these particles flying
around and these gases swirling and they
swirl and they fly and they glow and
they explode
and that's the cosmology we're in it's a
dead cosmology that's been dead so far
and in the usual story we'll be dead
forever except for this one little
sliver where we are which hardly matters
if rabi aliens are right now filling
half the universe and changing things
dramatically and in another billion
years will fill it all then cosmology is
a pretty different story
it's full of active agents with agendas
and we could be one of those agents and
take our place among them if we so
choose and that becomes the new
cosmology and it wouldn't mean that we
are much less important in Sun Cosmic
sense than we might otherwise have
thought if we thought thought we were
alone in the universe then there at
least on some moral theories we could
have a a duty to to survive and expand
and flourish in the universe but if the
universe is already filled with alien
civilizations maybe maybe our survival
is less important in some in some sense
well I mean the thing before was that
people had an unbounded estimate of how
much we could matter
however much it was it could be even
bigger than that and in this case it
would be bounded now it's still pretty
big that is our choice to be quiet or
loud would basically affect the nearest
million Galaxies for the next billion
years and that's all
the nearest million Galaxies for the
next billion years it's a lot the Lots
at stake there so I think it isn't like
oh now we don't matter anymore
it's just not infinite anymore it's it's
a bounded amount that we matter
but it's a lot and it changes our
self-perception perhaps
um in
well so it's not just like there's this
volume that will just stay dead and
empty unless we make it alive that's one
of the things at stake but another thing
is at stake is that when we finally meet
the aliens a billion years from now that
will just be the beginning of another
era that might last a hundred billion
years wherein we and these other alien
civilizations will be part of a
universe-wide community of aliens
and this in this community we will
interact
and we will each learn about each other
and then we'll each have to decide which
things about each other are we impressed
by and want to emulate that is we will
be culturally influenced by each other
and therefore we could each aspire to be
worthy of emulation in some interesting
way not in all ways but we could hope
that
our the universe will have descendants
of us not just because we control some
region of space that we defend but that
because we have something of value that
others recognize as having value and
that they take it on and spread it do
you think that in a billion years the
Notions we're talking about now will
will make sense so does it make sense
for as can we even
talk about uh once one enormously
Advanced civilization admiring and
another enormously Advanced civilization
do you think we risk kind of
extrapolating our Concepts too far here
this is the job of a theorist to to
basically identify our strongest most
powerful theories and to judge their
robustness
to judge how wide a range of
circumstances they possibly apply to
we we have the same task with physics
you could say we only know the physics
of the universe we're in and in the
future they will you know explore other
physical possibilities and therefore we
have no concept of the future physics
never we can't even talk about the
volume of space they'll be in or the
time it'll be they'll meet them and none
of that will be meaningless because our
concepts are meeting us that that seems
to me to go too far
I think I think the concept of space for
example and time are both going to be
robust Concepts that last for a long
time the speed of light limit on travel
I think is robust and that if it will
project and then if I look at Social and
biology and I say one of the most robust
Concepts seems to me
selection and reproduction are pretty
robust Concepts and they will last so I
can talk in terms of the future in terms
of selection and reproduction and that's
what I'm trying to you know use those
Concepts here we will spread out and
then we'll interact and there will be
cultural selection among that mix and
some things some elements will reproduce
and others won't
and we could we can aspire to have our
elements reproduce
Robin thank you this has been extremely
interesting
been great
that's it for this episode on the next
episode I talked with Robin about the
potential dangers of AI development and
why robin is skeptical of such scenarios